hallo mein name ist herzlich willkommen
leute zu einem neuen video habe gesehen
dass ihr das mega gefeiert hat als ich
mit einem 3d stirbt in 3d qualität
kultur mal habe ich hab ich noch auf
jeden fall gedacht das gibt's dann noch
ich bin durch die weiten des internet
gestöbert wir brauchen eigentlich
schwarzen filter und irgendwann epische
musik
ich bin durch die weiten des internet
gestöbert ich habe geschaut was gibt s
was wird man vielleicht machen was hat
irgendwie vielleicht auch was mit
stiften zu tun und dann bin ich auf die
idee kommt meine damen und herren ich
bestelle mir zugehört
[Musik]
ich hab mir auf jeden fall jetzt drei
stück bestellt einen in grün einen
blauen einen geld ich weiß mir die
wirkliche unterschiedliche farben
schreiben oder anders aussehen
hier steht wie ein stift mit
unsichtbarer tinte und schwarzlicht
inclusive batterien man kann damit
schreiben das verstecken und mit schwarz
sich das ganze dann hervorrufen hier ist
die schwarzlicht lampe hier ist die
unsichtbare tinte die kann die tinte
unsichtbar sein
auf der rückseite steht schreiben wie
mit dem stück mit der unsichtbaren tinte
eine nachricht nur beste beschreibung
ihrer leuchtend die mit dem schwarz
nicht darauf um die nachrichten sehen
der geheimschrift mit einer
erstaunlichen vielfalt an anwendungen
geheime nachrichten notfall taschenlampe
sicherheitsmarkierungen banknoten über
das machen wir gleich hier hat uns auf
jeden fall ein paar sachen überlegt wir
haben ja auch schon ein paar
verschiedene blätter in verschiedenen
farben werden das jetzt einfach mal
deutlich sagen
[Applaus]
wie schaut es mit welcher farbe wir
anfangen hält wird sagen badstuber steht
noch der weg vor dem den geld meine
damen und herren es ist kein zugegeben
aufführung verfahren
doch das tier doch beide usa sowie not
auch mit max riemelt shampoo zur
gewählten das ganze mal ausgeliehen
schnitt eine bärin der
leichtverpackungen man hat einfach das
jetzt auf jeden fall nun der stift der
it von einer marke ist auch gar nicht
darauf abgebildet
ich warte warte draußen also hier kein
dort keine marken hält macht mit
gehörschutz geschrieben um das zu
überprüfen
trotz der filter typische musik nun dazu
überprüfen widmen wir uns der diese
aufgabe dar überprüft also wie gesagt
wir schauen jetzt mal wie die marke
erkennen können wenn wir hier quasi
einfach mal drauf leuchten das heißt du
jetzt kommt ein werbevideo für den
termin ist okay gut die marke der
stifter haben wir herausgefunden
das heißt ich würde sagen wir fangen
jetzt erst mal mit einem stinknormalen
weißen blatt papier max ich würde sagen
ich mache nun etwas und du 58 das ganze
funktioniert ich mal jetzt mal so und
dann weil ich nicht so und dann mache
ich mal so und so seine art ist eine
behaltefrist liegen oder schulter wird
keiner hat ob erkennen wir gehen jetzt
in einem dunklen zimmer weise damen und
herren das heißt
morgen ich gar nicht ich muss halt leben
wir mit licht das ist nicht über sind im
ersten run geht aber der hardcore coole
auf junge wie das mit mir entlastung
bringen
wir machen noch auf anderen so leute
luca sitzt tot
okay wir haben jetzt auch weizen dort
ihren getestet das heißt als nächstes
habe ich jedoch eine bessere technologie
von stift kann man ist schwer zu
beschreiben
dafür werden zum praktischen leute
übrigens wenn jeder feiert konnte leute
wie habt ihr die schwarze papa das heißt
ich mache jetzt hier beispielsweise
einfach mal in den sprit männchen drauf
ich will man nicht weiß und dann lassen
sich die folge sagten strichmännchen
erstmals wird man nicht weiß was mich
einmal ihr könnt jetzt mal anschauen und
warten was einmal die kommentare was wir
machen also leute ich fange an und
zeichnen hier etwas was ich mache wird
hier eben die teile daran dann hier noch
[Musik]
und es muss eben nur kurz trocknen 2000
jahre später also leute wenn ihr wollt
dass schneller trocknet das allemal
direkt also das ganze ist jetzt
getrockneten hilfe niemals erkennen kann
vielleicht so ein zwei striche oder so
aber jemand wie man sagen würde haye
papier wird nicht verlängert
während der tat ausgezeichnet worden wir
gehen wieder in unsere
eine dunkelkammer durch ein stück
natürlich nicht verwischen normalen
licht aufleuchtete erkennt man ein
machen nicht bereits noch erstmal nicht
auf und jetzt möchte ich mal auch das
papier mit schwarzem mit ihm bevor ich
und kommentaren einfach wirklich nicht
wirklich auch in schwarz und aktivitäten
auf gelb und grün
wir haben jetzt einfach mal eben auf
diesen drei farben die ich mich hier
raus und hab das einfach beispielsweise
hier einfach mal hallo schreibe ich hier
draußen
[Musik]
ferdinand machen weil wir haben noch
eine andere challenge am start werden
wir das jetzt mal eben auch noch ganz
schnell nachschauen ob es möglich ist
also meine damen und herren bei
straftaten nicht gewichtige million mal
also wir haben hier lukas darauf stehen
kann man einigermaßen okay luc ackermann
noch erkennen dass auf dem grünen blatt
papier das auf der rechten oder das
überträgt stark also lange ist also auf
dem blauen sofa um geld naja aber auch
den blauen wasser aus dem hahn
das war schön und lustig aber bist du
bereit die zellen mit dem spotlight the
challenge kommen also wir haben ja hier
drei verschiedene stifte wie schnell wir
haben einmal den gelben dann haben wir
hier bei die werden glaube ich alle der
gleichen also wer geld hat ja auch nicht
gezeichnet hätten jetzt wieder ein
weißes blatt papier ich schreib mal mit
dem grünen hier beispielsweise grünen
eben drauf und schreibe mit dem blauen
jetzt einfach mal blau die vorne drauf
das hat bescheinigt worden dass wirklich
verschiedene farben sind ich glaube
deutlich weil der gelbe war auch
übermäßig ich liebe heraus
klassen also erkennen
also leute wir haben jetzt eine zeit ins
ausgedacht oder diese zellen so ein
bisschen von markt kommen wenig sagen
markt erklärt ihr euch mal okay zum
spiel folgendermaßen jeder von stick
drei blätter papier und ab entweder auf
die vorder- oder auf die rückseite was
schreiben mit geheim stimmt aber nur auf
ein blatt von den dreien dann werden
alle drei drin versteckt wir stocken die
zeit und gucken wie schnell der andere
das platten mit der nachricht daraufhin
okay leute luca mal da hinten gerade
eine nachricht auf ich warte weiter
fülliger weise mit hingucken
wir haben gerade 39 einem feiertag dass
du einfach mal nike glaubt dass wir
schon ein video machen für unter 1000
nicht nur ein leid und ich bin nicht
also ich was halten die sache perfekt
genommen
[Musik]
jetzt kommt ein werbevideo für den bug
schreibt sie gerade da vorne etwas auf
die kleine drauf magst du irgendetwas zu
sagen hin wichtig leicht verhältnis
heute max bädelt die teile hier eben da
vorne verstecken und thematisierte und
wir bieten dem rauchen drei wochen
später 32
[Musik]
[Applaus]
zwischenzeitlich werde ich mit
instrumenten die da unten rein zu denken
würde
18 sekunden gegen krieg und das hätte
ich auch von video meine damen und
herren länder siege darunter 1000 aber
ich habe auf jeden fall sind heutige
video aktive drei stück bestellt die
finden überarbeiten und ich mag euch
einfach eine legende beschreibung ist es
nicht verrückt platziert oder keine
ahnung was aber wenn ich sie haben
möchte weil beim training kam auch der
vielen nachfragen taucht einfach mal
irgendwo boxe ich würde auf jeden fall
mega gut geklappt hat man die kommentare
was ihre bewährte erfahrungen damit
gemacht hat und die findet nun hier
einen smiley eingeblendet wenn ihr
darauf sind immer im keller abonnieren
da unten auf meinen job eingebettet und
hier unten ist noch mal dass dieser
stift mal in 3d video verlinkt wo ich
auch mit einem stift in 3d und gemalt
habe